This episode is brought to you by our patrons
over at Patreon.com/journeytomicro.
Our patreon supporters are the reason videos
like this can exist, and right now, we’re
trying to hit a new goal of 900 monthly patrons.
Once we hit that goal, we’re going to be making
a special Microscopists React video where
a few of us from the Microcosmos team are
going to react to some of the good and not so
good microscopy that we’ve seen in tv shows
and movies.
I think it's going to be fun.
If you’d like to join our community and
help us hit our goal,
you can sign up for just $2 at patreon.com/journeytomicro.
Also if you have any microscopy-related scenes
that you’d like to see us react to, let
us know about them in the comments!
Do you know what’s in your water?
Do you know what’s buried deep in those
depths?
Sure, lakes and ponds have an idyllic quality
to them, and you could even picture yourself
spending a nice fall day in a canoe, your
hand passing through waters that feel cool
and refreshing against your skin.
But then, perhaps something else brushes up
against your hand too, a light touch you ignore
the first time, and then the second time as well.
Even the third time, maybe you manage to keep
your composure, though the movement is more
insistent and squirming than the first few
contacts.
And as it keeps happening, you realize you have
to see what it is.
So you peek into the water, and there they
are.
Worms.
Lots of them.
And their bodies can tell us more about those
waters than you might even want to know.
The worms themselves are not that scary, though,
from what we’ve learned, we imagine that
identifying them is going to be kind of a nightmare.
These worms are members of the genus Nais,
and even though there are only roughly 30
Nais species, we’re not sure exactly which
one we’re looking at here.
That ambiguity feels a little incongruent with the
worm that we see.
This is not a particularly subtle creature
to look at.
There are large squiggles and bright colors.
But the specific feature that scientists use
to determine what species they’re looking at
is this.
Those are tiny hairs, known better as chaetae.
And as you can see, they’re quite small.
And the number of features you could use to
describe them seems minimal.
Yet scientists have to rely on these tiny
structures to try and apply a name tag to
the worms they’re studying.
In the words of one paper, the differences
between these chaetae
“are often subtle, inconsistent, and even
overlapping between nominal species”.
Honestly, it sounds like a nightmare to me.
James, our master of microscopes, usually
finds these worms in the ponds around him.
They’re very common, and they’re also
very useful…
just in a kind of creepy way.
Because these worms dance.
And not to insult them or anything, but their dances are
kind of unsettling to watch.
The worms are partially buried in the sediment,
but the part that we can see…
well, they’re hard to miss.
They look like a hallucination you might conjure
up of The Rockettes performing choreography
inspired by an Edvard Munch painting.
But the odd thing is that this dancing…
this is what makes the worms useful to James.
If the worms are dancing like this, it means
that there’s a lot of oxygen dissolved in
the water.
When the oxygen concentration starts to go
down though, the worms will start to emerge
further from the sediment.
And as the levels keep going down, the worms
keep rising and rising in the water until
they’re right under the water line.
And as they rise, they stop dancing.
So for James, who is often looking out for organisms
who might prefer a low-oxygen environment,
the dancing of the worms are his own biological
oxygen meter, helping him gauge the conditions
and its effects on the creatures he’s looking
after.
And while this is very neat, and very useful
for James, it is also a bit of a mystery because
we have no idea why they do this.
We’ve looked through papers and tried to
find an explanation, but we only have our
guesses.
James thinks their dance is most likely some
kind of way to filter the water around them
for food.
But if any of you have an explanation, we
would love to hear it.
This dancing isn’t the first time someone
has used worms from this genus to understand
the waters around them.
In fact, nais worms have been an important
part of a widespread scientific effort to
understand something far more horrific.
Between 1995 and 1996, researchers ventured
to a lake near the village of Yanov in Ukraine
to find worms.
The village had been evacuated nearly a decade
before, emptied of people and filled with
radiation following the explosion of the Chernobyl
Nuclear Power Plant in 1986.
But plenty of animals remained, and scientists
wanted to know what the effect of radiation
in Chernobyl had been on them and the ecosystem
around them.
Some scientists looked at mice, others looked
at carp and catfish.
These scientists chose worms.
After all, they’re incredibly important
in aquatic ecosystems, growing into large
populations that help transport and transform
organic matter throughout their watery world.
So they gathered worms in the lake near Chernobyl,
including two species of Nais worms.
And then they gathered the same species from
a lake 20 kilometers away.
These lakes were similar in many ways: similar
temperatures, similar chemical compositions.
The major difference, of course, was the radiation.
The sediments near Chernobyl were loaded with
radioactive strontium—
around 55 times more than that in the distant
lake.
And the worms themselves were getting dosed
with around 20 times more radiation in that
contaminated lake.
That radiation broke up bits of the worm’s
DNA, leaving fragments that were then patched
back up—
but not perfectly.
The scientists could see the mistakes left
behind in the worm’s chromosomes.
It’s one thing to find a mistake or two
in the cells—
that can happen spontaneously.
But what the scientists found was more than
double the rate of that kind of mistake, leaving
behind a build-up of aberrations embedded
genetically within the worm.
And the scientists also found something else,
a change of behavior in the worms.
Nothing like the dance we saw earlier, but
something that’s unexpected for these worms:
sex.
Nais worms can reproduce sexually, but they
tend not to.
In fact, this is part of why they’re difficult
to study compared to worms in related genuses.
Often, those worms are distinguished by the
shape of their genitals.
But the Nais are so rarely engaged in sexual
reproduction that they don’t often have
what scientists delicately describe as a
“fully-developed sexual apparatus.”
That lack of obvious genitalia makes it
difficult to identify them.
And yet in the contaminated lake, Nais worms
were more likely to pursue sexual reproduction
compared to their counterparts, a strategy
likely meant to help them introduce variations
in their genome that might allow them to adapt
to the new stresses of their environment, particularly that radiation.
Decades later, perhaps that lake is filled
with the worms borne of those many couplings.
And maybe they’re there, dancing in the
sediment, while they bear the genetic legacy
of a catastrophic event.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us
These people on the screen right now, they
are some of our Patreon Patrons.
We really, really like making this show, and
we have a lot of people who support us.
And we are so grateful for them.
So if you want to thank anybody for the existence
of this YouTube channel, these are some of
the names of those people.
If you'd like to join them, you can do that
by going to patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.